you so rich but but the point is like
why why do as women we feel entitled to
a man's money because you helped raise
the kids no but that's a lot in the
states right this doesn't apply like in
most other okay but we're not we're in
the UK even in the UK women don't
naturally that's not right that's not
true um even I don't necessarily know
what it is for divorce but from I've
heard a lot of like I get DMS from
people constantly and I've gotten horror
stories from Men in the UK and I I do
Street interviews horror stories of
Child Support so it's it's no different
and it's you're in the west we're not
talking about global if I have to give
up my career for you to build something
and then you cheat on me and we have to
get divorced big man give me my money